session was held this morning that
included parts of the las vegas strip
and it ended at
central christian church in henderson
a final ride around the valley for metro
police detective justin terry as law
enforcement from all across the state
came to show support it never gets
easier but yes they're very distinctive
detective terry was brought to central
christian church his family had these
words to share trust me i can go on for
hours telling you all how great he was
but i will say that i cannot be more
thankful to have had him as a dad
i owe him everything for who i am today
the funeral service for detective terry
with almost 21 years with metro included
a picture montage of his life
highlighting his biggest moments on and
off the clock he loved his job
it was all he ever wanted to do
for him it was a vocation
a calling
but aside from all that
justin was everything to his family
detective terry died june 10 when a
steel beam fell on his unmarked police
vehicle on u.s 95. many said he made a
big impact in the community since a big
focus was protecting vulnerable children
throughout his career it's hard to put
into words you know when you get a loss
like this and
just really
really feel for las vegas metropolitan
police department and the sheriff and
all the officers friends family it's
just truly just such a huge loss
detective terry's family added that he
was a role model for them as well as a
protector the injured officers police
fund is raising money and if you wish to
help we have a link on our website
8newsnow.com